so among the places that Canton open as
we mentioned were indoor malls and
meadows mall officially reopened their
doors today and some big changes have
been put in place 8 News Now reporter or
co-manage ording us now live from inside
the mall with a closer look at those
changes orco
well Denise today is the first time in
more than two months that meadow small
has been open to the public and shoppers
are excited there are some noticeable
changes including these hand sanitizer
stations but both businesses and
customers tell us that they're happy
things are finally starting to get back
to normal a steady stream of shoppers
make their way through Meadows mall oh
my gosh we're so excited to finally be
opening after more than two months of
kovat 19 closures the mall is back in
business
general manager Heather Cox says several
changes have been made to keep shoppers
safe you know we want our customers to
feel comfortable coming shopping at our
Center we have we have a lot of signage
we have added a lot of new sanitizing
stations throughout the shopping center
our security is walking around handing
out masks individual stores inside the
mall like Brad's toys are also doing
their part to protect patrons we have
like hand sanitizer we have our masks
and everything and we're just trying to
make sure that everyone's going to be
safe they were thrilled to have
customers come back that's been going
great having and Gus teens ice cream is
serving tasty treats for the first time
it started construction just about the
time that everything went into
quarantine
we're about two months too late but
we're helping everybody besides coming
back down shoppers tell us they feel
safe they're following all the rules I
see a lot of hand sanitizers next to
like the cashier spots and you know
there and everybody seems to be on the
critical when it comes to sanitizing and
that is mall management's top priority
we feel like we have made the steps that
we need to to make sure that we can
provide a safe place for the community
to come and shop
some of the stores inside Meadows mall
like this one here are still closed but
we're told many of them will reopen over
the next few days the mall also has
reduced hours it's open from Monday to
Saturday 11 to 7 p.m. and on Sundays
from noon to 6 reporting live at meadows
mall tonight Orko mana 8 News now